en sport de pétrole part très inquiète
de plus en plus de gens ça non oui
l'inquiétude est vive en était à même de
le constater dans les tribunes
téléphoniques dans les lettres d'opinion
beaucoup de canadiens de québécois
s'inquiètent de voir qu'il ya de plus en
plus de transports de matières
dangereuses notamment de pétrole par
trait au pays
alors on va prendre un peu de recul mais
sur un peu a refusé de se prononcer sur
la question ce n'est pas le temps selon
lui
mais on va se donner la liberté de
regarder ça d'un peu plus près voyons
tout d'abord ici une carte géographique
du centre et de l'ouest du pays
et vous voyez les voyez ici c'est le
réseau assez tentaculaire de tout ce qui
est laid finalement le réseau
ferroviaire au pays donc la saskatchewan
de l'alberta le manitoba
ça va bien au nord où sont les sables
bitumineux en alberta et tout ça aussi
vers la colombie-britannique prince
rupert
mais les grands installations portuaires
qui amène tout ça vers des marchés
pétroliers notamment asiatiques là on
est dans l'est du pays le québec le nord
du québec les régions les régions
ressources
très riche en matière donc minières
notamment et aussi l'atlantique et le
pacifique qui a faut le souligner un
vélo la compagnie irving d'énormes
raffinerie à halifax en tout cas dans la
nouvelle-écosse au nouveau-brunswick qui
achemine le pétrole vers les marchés
notamment européens donc ça c'était pour
qu'on visualise l'étendue du réseau
ferroviaire où transitent ces traits de
plus en plus de ces trains contiennent
du pétrole dans des wagons citernes
allons voir maintenant des données des
données notamment qui ont été relevés
par la presse canadienne et n'ajustez
pas votre appareil ce que vous allez
voir là ce sont bien des données et qui
semble réel transport de pétrole par
très une augmentation de 6 en cinq ans
de 28000 % augmentation du transport de
pétrole par train de 28 % en cinq ans à
la grandeur du pays d'un océan à l'autre
selon les données de l'association des
chemins de fer du canada en 2009 il y
avait en une année en 2009 500 wagons
citernes contenant du pétrole qui
transitaient au cours de cette année
cette année là et en 2013 quatre ans
plus tard 140000 wagon citerne qui
transportait du pétrole donc dans leur
contenu un wagon citerne on calcule que
c'est environ 600 baril de pétrole voyez
à quel point donc ce sont des cadets des
quantités assez importantes
va changer maintenant de tableau pour
vous présenter d'autres données et des
données qui nous donne ou encore une
fois une idée de ces proportions
voisines et une tarte si on veut si vous
permettez ce terme estime un familier
ici la portion au bleu poudre bleue pâle
c'est finalement là dans les trains de
marchandises la proportion qui
représente les hydrocarbures et les
produits chimiques c'est 20 % ses
cinquièmes on voit que c'est important
donc et pour qu'on se tourne de plus en
plus vers les trains via le réseau de
pipelines qu'on veut et ambre mais
beaucoup de ces projets sont en suspens
on pensera et à qui se tourne excellent
donc l'industrie pétrolière et gazière
de plus en plus se rabat sur les trains
et pour les trains en avance aussi que
c'est notamment moins cher de le faire
ici
mais est-ce que c'est nécessairement
plus sécuritaire on voit ici donc selon
les données de l'association des chemins
de fer du canada les accidents au cours
des dernières années serait en baisse
selon leurs données entre 2005 et 2010
donc on enregistre une baisse mais
notamment césar cesser ces accidents
existent pas seulement au pays voici ici
en 2009 des images qui nous proviennent
de l'illinois il ya un déraillement de
train c'était de la cn train du cn qui
contenait du pétrole à ce moment là il
ya eu les autorités américaines qui ont
fait enquête et ses capes ses wagons
citernes que l'on observe ici n'était
pas assez sécuritaire selon leurs
conclusions hors des gens interrogés par
le new york times sur la tragédie du lac
mégantic ont observé les wagons-citernes
que l'on voyait dans les photos dans les
vidéos et selon leur analyse
préliminaire ses wagons citernes a
seraient antérieurs à ceux ci donc
présumément encore moins sécuritaire
alors voila si voilà c'était simplement
pour vous dresser un portrait de la
situation
c'est à dire de l'augmentation du
transport du pétrole par train qui
inquiète de plus en plus de canadiens
des craintes que certains et que
plusieurs même qualifierais de justifier
merci beaucoup alexis voilà un point
fort intéressant et c'est incroyable on
des données comme cela 28000 %
l'augmentation du transport du pétrole
par train incroyable merci alors le
débat du pipeline va reprendre de plus
belle
et des prolongements pipeline merci
beaucoup plus impression alexis